How does the moon still have so many mysteries?
We beat you, moon, give up your secrets.
Don’t make us send Buzz back up there!
Hello moon men and women, Julian here for
DNews.
The moon is our little celestial sidekick,
the Robin to Earth’s Batman.
And ever since we’ve noticed it up there
we’ve come up with all sorts of myths and
theories of how it got there.
For the last 40 years, we’ve had a explanation
we were mostly satisfied with, but now a new
study published in the journal Nature Geoscience
has revived the discussion of the moon’s
origin.
The study suggests that the moon was formed
a little bit at a time as small planetoids
hit a young proto earth over and over 4 billion
years ago.
Back then, the solar system was still just
getting together and sorting itself out, so
collisions of these forming space chunks were
a lot more common.
Each time one hit, it would kick up a cloud
of debris that would settle into a ring of
dust around our forming planet.
Eventually the orbiting dust would coalesce
and the little ball of moon chunk would move
away from our planet over the course of centuries.
Then another planetoid would hit and the whole
process would repeat.
The moon bits would interact in space, sometimes
causing them to be ejected or collide with
earth again, and occasionally they’d come
together and form something greater… like
an orbiting moon-fragment megazord.
This study is similar to the current most
popular explanation for the moon, called the
giant impact hypothesis.
I think you can see where they’re different
though: instead of lots of smaller impacts
over a long period of time, the giant impact
hypothesis does all its moon forming in one
go.
Baby Earth was smacked by another Mars-sized
object called Theia, made a huge debris cloud,
and then that cloud reformed into the moon
we see today.
The giant impact hypothesis has been the favorite
since it was proposed in the 70s, but it’s
not perfect.
The biggest issue is the composition of the
moon and Earth are really similar, which isn’t
what you’d expect if two large objects smack
into each other.
We think that when the planets formed, their
composition depended a lot on how far they
were from the sun.
The farther away they were, the more likely
they were to retain heavier isotopes of elements.
So Earth and Mars have different levels of
certain isotopes like silicon, but somehow
Earth and our moon have surprisingly similar
levels of silicon, oxygen, and titanium.
To explain the similarities, Theia would either
have to have formed roughly the same distance
from the sun as the Earth, or when it hit
the Earth it would have to have been spinning
in just the right way to kick up more Earth
material so the moon’s composition matches
ours.
It’s not out of the question, but it certainly
seems unlikely.
Previous models of single giant impacts showed
a moon like ours forming only 1-2% of the
time.
This is what lead the researchers to model
what might happen if the Earth was occasionally
bombarded with smaller planetesimals instead
of big ol’ Theia.
They found that if the moon is built up over
time, the composition of the impactors can
be different from the Earth’s, but the debris
will average out and mask what the original
planetesimals were made of.
When the researchers simulated this scenario
800 times, they found there was better than
a 10% chance of getting the moon we see today.
Not great, but better!
Of course, they say their model raises other
issues, like how these smaller impacts could
give our Earth and Moon the angular momentum
we see today, and for that their proposal
needs more study.
But it raises the possibility that we once
had multiple smaller moons.
Or as I call them, moon moons.
While we only have the one moon now, other
planets in our solar system have them in the
double digits.
Why did we get stuck with just the one?
Well Trace talks about that here.
So which sounds better to you, Giant Impact
Hypothesis or assembling the moon, Ikea style?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe for
more and we'll see you next time on DNews.
By the way it's my birthday.